joining us now is Helen King a former
assistant commissioner at the
Metropolitan Police Service thank you so
much for coming to the studio this
morning it's appreciate it good morning
um I just want to talk about a story
that broke yesterday uh the head of the
police Watchdog resigning because the
police are investigating a historical
allegation about him
I mean you really couldn't make it up
well obviously I don't know any more
than is in the Press already and clearly
what needs to happen is that
investigation needs to go ahead no doubt
the individual concerned is under under
huge pressure and his family and so on
as well and that process has to run but
at the same time everyone the public
complainants police officers need to be
able to have confidence in the iopc as
well and the the the investigations that
they carry out I don't think you're
completely right of course that we don't
know the details of the allegation it
would be absolutely wrong to make any uh
judgments there
um but I guess the police investigation
it seems has been going on for some time
and yet Michael look would only stepped
aside when the Home Secretary told him
to either quit or be suspended it feels
like there's question marks that the
iopc was even aware of the allegation I
as I say I know no more than is in the
Press it's important that the police
complaint system is one that both
officers and the public can have
confidence in and I think one of the the
constructive debate that is happening at
the moment is looking at the way
allegations against the police including
internal police misconduct
investigations are dealt with to make
sure that police Chiefs can sack police
officers where that's appropriate and
that those investigations can be
concluded more quickly and in ways that
have public and officer confidence yeah
to talk about the public confidence in
the police but also other institutions
as well because it does feel like
there's been I guess already almost
classed as like a misogyny crisis and
some of these institutions and the
London Farm Brigade are described as
institutionally misogynistic and racist
reports that people have in their helmet
filled with urine Muslim offices having
pork sausages put in their pockets and
of course the Met police too the some of
the WhatsApp messages exchange between
officers joking about rape and domestic
violence do you think there is
institutional misogyny and racism in
some of these organizations
um let's be frank the the behaviors
you've described are absolutely
despicable
um and something that both we the public
but also the good the many thousands of
of really good committed officers
firefighters and so on will also find
disgusting and what dealt with
but let's be frank this isn't new I
think in a sense it's good that these
conversations are being had it's
following on from the me too movement
um let's look at Parliament you know
you've been a political correspondent I
suspect that you know there's been
um maybe old boys clubs and and networks
in a wide range of Institutions I think
certainly Parliament is not somewhere to
throw stones I think you're probably
definitely right exactly public and
private sector but absolutely right that
it's now being exposed and of course
those who are put in positions of trust
which police officers firefighters
emergency workers are they do an
incredible job but we need to be able to
have confidence in them so it's right
that these behaviors are exposed and
dealt with but at the same time we need
to think about how do we attract and
keep really good stuff those who have
the moral Courage the ethical resilience
to do these really difficult jobs where
they're dealing with tragedy they're
dealing with horrible situations they're
dealing often with hostility from the
public they feel they're under attack by
the media by politicians and now we look
at the the state of our public services
and the amount of work they're having to
do not always with the resources that
they need
so I think there's a question for all of
us yes for leaders of these institutions
but also for us to say how do we make
sure that we have the public services
that we deserve and we support those who
are doing these incredibly difficult
jobs on our behalf I'm interested on
your thoughts on what can change what
can actually practically be done and the
report in November example for example
found some recent examples of people who
were cleared to join the police when
they had past convictions for indecent
exposure assaults on women even an
arrest for rape do you think the vetting
is up to scratch
um vetting can always be improved but I
do think it's a blunt tool you can
generally only rely upon convictions
and of course people with the wrong
attitudes who are joining for the wrong
reasons
um may be hiding that so you've got to
have the right training you've got to
have the right type of supervision and
Leadership and a culture where people
will be reported by their peers and then
a system that can push them out of the
organization at the moment police
regulations are unwieldy police Chiefs
aren't the ones who are making the
decisions about who should be sacked or
not
um and I think it's right that that is
being opened up question yeah that was
interesting because the new met police
chief samark Rowley um in a recent
interview said that you know he has to
employ a hundred people who are only
allowed to work in back room roles and
he said it's completely mad that I had
to employ people like that as police
officers who you can't trust have
contact with the public so is there a
problem about effective not be able to
stack people yes
um some years ago and I understand why
from a public perception point of view
um the makeup of police misconduct
panels was changed so that there's a
legally qualified chair rather than a
senior police officer who chairs those
panels I chaired dozens of those panels
during my my service and my experience
of sitting with lay members is that they
tend to be more sympathetic towards
police officers
um maybe more understanding uh you know
in a way that I felt actually they
shouldn't be and police officers have to
maintain the highest standards of
behavior because they're enforcing the
law on fellowship with fellow citizens
um so I do think that's one of a number
of things that should be looked at in
terms of the way police misconduct is
dealt with you know you obviously in the
worked for the police did you witness
any of this kind of behavior or was it
things that are I guess more generally
kept within groups of men or did you see
anything or right by the by the time I
joined the met I was very senior I was a
police officer for 30 years in in three
different police forces
um I'm not sure it's very helpful to
start talking about incidents that
happened 35 years ago but I think all
women who've worked in male dominated
organizations
um
um people from LGBT communities people
from different ethnic backgrounds when
you're in a minority within an
organization and that can feel like
quite a lonely place I think the recent
report about the fire service is is
worth a read and it includes in that an
example of what a good team looks like
where everyone feels that they're
pulling together and the different
strengths are seen to be making the team
more stronger
um themselves but I think sometimes when
you're the only one and the team ethos
is about
um a very traditional view
yeah which which emphasizes maybe the
physicality of policing or firefighting
and not recognizing that actually the
breadth of skills that you need to work
effectively as a team means that you
need different people within that team
yeah I thought one of the really
interesting parts of that report into
the London fire brigade was the figures
on just how white a male an organization
it is
um you've said before that policing is
an attractive career for sexual
predators bullies and bigots now I know
that you've also emphasized the really
good people who work in the police and
it's important to say that but what did
you mean by that well
as I as I said before as a police
officer you have power over your fellow
citizens and also the way
um policing tends to be portrayed in the
media it's about Pub fights it's about
driving cars fast it's the more Macho
side if you like of the role whereas
actually the figures show now about 80
percent of police incidents don't even
involve a crime uh the police more and
more are picking up issues that come
from people in Mental Health crisis
people with all sorts of vulnerabilities
missing children missing elderly people
and so on so
um
the way policing is seen if you start up
from from a position where maybe you are
a bully or a bigot it looks like an
attractive career to you and so that's
why recruitment training
um and an internal culture that does
report those who really don't deserve to
carry the warrant card or to wear the
uniform and there is increasing evidence
of that
um and Reporting hotlines and so on that
that people can use I went on one of
those websites the other day where
people give Anonymous reviews of their
employers and when you look at the one
for the Metropolitan Police there are a
number of people who say they're they're
former officers complaining that you
can't trust your colleagues any net
anymore because they might report on you
yeah and I actually thought that that
was a very positive sign that people are
realizing you can't get away with
behavior where maybe you thought you
were safe in the past just to pick up
very quickly before we end on something
you just said 80 of police incidents
don't involve a crime yes I'm quite
staggered by that do you think that's
because you're effectively having to
take on a greater role in Pub where
Public Services other public services
like the Health Service or whatever are
stretched it's always been true but I
suspect even more so now
um policing sometimes gets called The
Social Services of Last Resort
of all the organizations that are
available 24 hours a day seven days a
week the police in effect the last one's
left standing and I think we would all
want somebody to go and help the most
vulnerable in their hour of need but the
point that Mark Rowley is is making at
the moment is that that does become a
distraction and depletes resources from
those incidents that really only the
police can deal with and that's going to
be a challenge for Society for those
um deciding where where taxpayers money
goes within the public sector
fascinating didn't realize that at all
thank you so much for being on the
program today really interesting to talk